Kathy is with us in Houston Texas hi
Kathy how are you fine thank you for
taking my call
sure how can I help I want you to settle
an argument between my husband and I
we're dead free but we have this one
issue where he wants to use a credit
card but he pays it off every month and
I don't think that that's what we
learned in FPE
I thought we were supposed to only use
debit cards mm-hmm so is the argument
what to do or what whether result about
what you learned in it to you is he
debating what you learned enough to you
yes sort of he thinks he learned enough
to unit that's keeping a credit cards
okay one that he pays off every month he
thought he learned that enough to you
right well he flunked the class he has
to go back through where do I find the
information to show him that well just
get the dumping debt lesson out I've
never told a lie to keep a credit card
in my life okay that's what I said no
absolutely you haven't told anybody do
that now is he going are y'all gonna go
bankrupt for doing this no probably not
absolutely not we did first you're
arguing about what you learned in the
class or what Dave Ramsey teaches that's
a very clear thing I haven't had a
credit card in 20 plus years and I don't
tell people no credit cards I don't have
a debit card debit card will do
everything your credit card will do
which by the way if you're paying it off
every month anyway you're using you got
the money already before you buy it
so the debit card does exactly the same
thing it's not really you know you know
it's just like y'all hang anything to
fight about this week so you dreamed up
something to fight about I mean but but
yeah you're right you win the argument
Financial Peace University teaches you
to have no credit cards they Ramsey
teaches you to have no credit cards to
use debit cards and if you use a credit
card and you're paying it off every
month it's the same thing as a debit
card is it Deb so chop up the stupid
credit card accept debit cards I'm gonna
let you go into that this is coming out
your checking account but if you got the
money in your account anyways you're
gonna use to pay off
there's no big difference none
whatsoever
except that stupid credit card has the
ability to accidentally oh I forgot to
pay it up this month now I've got that
again and there we are you can wander
your butt back into a mess now I don't
think y'all are gonna do that Kathy I
think you're probably okay but as far as
the who wins the argument you do is that
easy hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]